all right Ricky's just really funny
Ricky's well my name is Pete
but it's repeat because I'm fair and
down here that's really a particular
train it's really a good trade but you
don't get it everybody's trying to win
it revisited nickel they're trying to
get over me I'm gonna give you what you
pay for I might give you more than what
you pay for
but I'm never gonna give you lessons I'm
always going to be quality so what you
do with me you don't want to repeat the
process South Central Los Angeles right
here I grew up when I was born it was
the area called Bob town it was where
the school Bethune is but don't dream
your high but it was an apartment
complex
what they did was eminent domain to the
public complex made us move and built
the rest of the school just be resaw boy
school it's on 69th in our Main Street
both your parents my father died 1967 my
brother was a mono man you know who's
been there was a mono hood and I was
four years old my father died of a
heroin overdose and then the guys
instead of table table you know glad
that everybody's dumped him in an alley
you know so after day I grew up when I
was 13 I gravitated away from gang
membership even though I never wanted it
by a scuba-diving I ran into an
individual who took me out in this boat
while he was diving I thought it was the
most incredible thing in the world
specially I used to watch Sea Hunt so
when we finished ask me do you think I
might be in a dive he said sure if
you're not scared and that's what I was
planning on so the next day he went and
rented me a wetsuit you got enough gear
for two people so I put the gear on
Adobe asked me would I think I said was
the best thing that ever happened in my
life I want to do it again so the next
weekend he brought me a wetsuit you know
and from the island every weekend
I started a fish business I would sell
fish fillet down in the quarter pound
I'd bring up about 600
to fish so I have like eight $900 I'm
only 14 years old at this time but I've
seen her 16 a power for cars a
motorcycle and I moved into a
double-wide mobile home for $38,000
that's how much capital I say well I got
in trouble because even though I had
their money I'm kind of like a car thief
you know and to me it's it was the
exciting thing as a drill in flow I got
caught stealing the car I went before
the judge
my attorney asked me what are you gonna
be doing for the summer I said well I'm
get a summer job you said that's not
enough I know this judge you got to give
me something I said well I was going to
the baby I had been talking to a
recruiter I never intended on going you
know just talking to him and uh he said
well I'll see you back in court so he
got in court your honor
I was address to court he says my client
here that plans on going to United
States Navy but if this fairly
persistent he's found he's convicted you
want me to go in a neighbor any other
forces but Jenna said did you read up on
that
he says yes I talked to a petty officer
first class Hall just do it on the board
he said okay it was release mr. mr.
Depina and dropped his family when would
be the soon as he could leave he said
tomorrow the judge said well you got a
choice you can fight this case you do
three here or you do three there what
did you choose I said all right sir next
day I was in the United States Navy I
went in as a mechanic's meeting
underwater welder
they made me in at 16 three months
before I turned 17 they gave me a waiver
because I had a particular skill I was
already a diver and you had to teach me
that aspect so when the Navy the Navy
wasn't exciting for me I got in trouble
a few times like everybody else but I
never started drinking that's why today
I do not drink at all
after the baby well I have my daughter
my little baby but after the Navy about
two three blocks on the street I didn't
like it so I went into the or me it's
over a lifetime 82nd airborne parents
expressed is that everything that
concerns to parachute in 1983 October
24th the Cuban invaded I never Nader you
see that movie with Clint Eastwood
called a heartbreak ridge or whatever
and the Marines go mm at the end it
wasn't a range
it was 82nd airborne so army did that
maneuver the Marines were nowhere around
anyway I lasted five days on the island
I got hit with a 82 millimeter mortar
round it blew up in front of me and it
shredded my face they tore my helmet off
and knocked my finger off I couldn't
find it for a while is only attached by
the skin and a split lip horrible day
I got shot twice to my frag jacket we
didn't have dragons like you have
nothing but a few jackets we had
fragmentation proof jackets so one way
I'm HIPPA the stomaching came out my
back I'm gonna hit me in the ribs
through the scene and it broke two of my
ribs and I can reach in I can feel it
but I was trying to pull it up but it
was too sticky to embed it so through
that night I was gaining well first I
woke up because the ground was vibrating
the 105 howitzers was 11 miles away but
they still have enough force to shake
the ground the ground kept sinking so I
open my eyes and I looked I had blood -
I was
blast flash blinded blast death I kept
seeing these bees take off I remember
where I placed the m60 because I did the
gun emplacement I remember where I
placed it and out watch these bees go
and I reason out that's the m16
so I crawled in the direction the bees
was coming from but I got close enough
respect for Ramsey pulled me in and I
told her look tell my wife that I didn't
die like a punkin I went through these
things thinking I was about to face
death anyway through that night I was
you I would gain consciousness I would
lose consciousness
and I woke up when they put me out of
the foxhole I've broke my right
collarbone
they put me up by my right on everybody
I remember waking up
I remember being put in a helicopter
because the down blast was in my face I
remember a lady singing make sure
everybody secured we're about to land
and I remember somebody saying do you
feel this I woke up in heaven I thought
it was because I was under the surgical
light I tried to I knew I had patches on
face I tried to sit up and feel like
somebody took a stick about 12 inches
long and stuck inside my stomach cuz I
couldn't be in my muscles was tired I
tried to live in my hands and I was
wearing a Houdini jacket
it made me panic I started shaking in
the jacket I called a nurse she ran in
there I said [ __ ] if you don't take
this [ __ ] off of me I'm gonna kill you
since I'm not taking net nothing I'll
kill nobody
she said you came in here violent and
you're still biting so we're gonna leave
it on until you calm down I broke down
please okay stop crying
i'ma call a doctor if you simply take it
off take it off come Tuesday the doctor
comes in with two orderlies hey are you
gonna be calm I mean you came in but I
think I'll tell you what happened but
we're gonna take it off if you act up
we're gonna hold you down we're gonna
put you back in the straitjacket on duty
James Holmes took the straitjacket on
she says you attacked the corner when
you were landing in Florida and I
remembered not attacking them
I remember that lady saying make sure
everybody secured they say it came to
pull your hornets tight and you woke up
you put on the field for Nelson and you
bout to take him out we had to shoot you
up he said man you woke up on a surgical
table the doctor had his hand inside of
you and he was so amazed when you woke
up you guys you did you feel this and
you said [ __ ] do you feel
listen he's grabbing her nephew star
choking so we knock you out again you
see that's why we woke up we put a
straitjacket on you because you about an
individual I said well when I went out
yeah I remember was that war we were
fighting so I guess it returned I
revived I was back in his own anyone
else what happened he said the surgeon
did a good job on your face he said well
I remember holding my face up I have
someone that go it was dripped down I
was like I'm [ __ ] up man
but he said the surgeon did a very
particular job in microsurgery in a
couple of years people won't even notice
the scars you have to show them where
the scars are when I look in the mirror
I still see gigantic scars well I spend
a lot of time in front of the mirror but
he was right when most people say oh I
didn't wear you know yeah a scar so you
see there's no scar here this one here
this one here up down in my hand I might
have I got blow off the chip to piece of
my skull you'll see these scars not
really no answer that's why I wear a
beard I keep a beard so I don't wanna
see the scar himself I said my finger
came off my finger was back here because
they had my hand up and I was feeling
for my finger and I found it this
hanging I took it I put it in my hand I
bought my fish stuff I took my first aid
kit off my back and I'll wrap my hand up
he said it was a good thing you did that
we were able to reattach the fingers he
said the tendon is severed we won't get
to reattach that but you'll get some
feeling back and you'll have some type
of motion and this is emotion I had
which makes it good [ __ ] you feel it
when you see it we're leaving your right
palm open up because we wanted to heal
from the inside out
we don't want to close loving then it
doesn't heal inside they said your back
is the same difference they said around
we found it around between your skin and
a jacket or one of your ribs
it broke two ribs are things we do is
table mother we want you to have a
bottle moving and do different things
that's most a blender stool anyway now
I'm vibe I got through that ordeal I
know post-traumatic stress syndrome at
that time six months later after I left
on me and I started selling drugs
because it was a thing to do
1985 free with ripping restaurant I mean
we called it balling when you sold drugs
got their Rolls Royce of that Mercedes
and all the toys you know the women go
to jury can Rose worth a lot of heavy
gold chain
a sign of you'll rise in sign of order
so uh what I used to do was nice to Jack
ballers they talk too much
and they would get you're talking down
for hey man I know you live you're like
75 now I'm on 65th all season filled by
Kim Nam by Craig I had their blue house
today would give me all the information
I wanted I would follow them for five or
six days and when the time was right
I'd go in but I never took anybody with
me at the time I went in I was prepared
to kill everybody in the house mama
daddy dog cat goldfish anything that
moved
once I start shooting I was gonna hit
everything but me I never had to do that
because I became what they called a
creeper I've been there and you've never
seen and everything gone that's how
people know was me they said we didn't
see nobody we didn't hear that it had to
be him it had to be him but I would have
my brother my brother was on top of the
world I would have him I would give him
the money and he would show up in front
of everybody and hand me a lot of money
I said oh that's what guys when we got
it from his brother no it was they money
I just made it look as though my brother
gave to me I would give him like 14
$15,000 I mean I was getting two hundred
eighty six thousand sixty four thousand
and four Birds a bird we're making
hundred thousand dollars when I went in
I went in by myself and again I went in
one house and it was nine dudes in there
I came through the Attic I pulled the
Vince off I walked on the Joyce I found
interest into the house because there's
always a crawlspace
there's always adding interest I pulled
it up I entered the house quite a 357
Magnum
I drew down everybody everybody was
sleeping I said there dude blue diamond
razor blade and I cut everybody pockets
up front and back ass cheeks to the wind
I took everything he had after talking
on a drug head and I took every piece of
weapon that was in the house
that's how they know it's me because
they didn't hear anything and they know
at this time I was only one only one
boating after coming house
with nine different killers and take
this [ __ ] so anyway else I made a
decision my wife at this time asked me
to go to the store and get some milk
first but a cereal for my son now this
is my best decision I said I'm going to
wrap supermarket four blocks away I'm
going to need 32 9 gram bags of cocaine
go for block I'm gonna need a 357 Magnum
a 38 Smith & Wesson
a 25 automatic a sawed-off shotgun and a
hard man 22 rifle oh I need 1,800
bullets I put 1,800 rounds and I told
man yeah I went to the store to get some
milk
I told her I'll be right back what had
happened was at this time we used to pay
people to use their cars like a $50
right hundred out of rocks I can't do
the $50 ride I suppose that was clever
like two or three days when he went home
his wife couldn't appreciate it so she
called the police and reported the car
stolen the I am going around supermarket
I walk out the house the car has a
ticket on it I don't really trip let's
take the ticket off the window go in the
glove box
the pony's down the street I never seen
him I stuck the car up and I pull off
but I got to the corner
the ponies put up behind me and they hit
the lights
and it got on my phone I got off the car
threw down over you in the car
throw the keys out the winner once your
handler that's the last days he's my
head go see my ass because I'm free to
run but the light was red and it was
cars in front of me so they got the car
now get out who wants your hand and I
was paying attention to them I didn't
know they like to change until I seen
that diesel from smoke I'm a bus and I
look the bus was gone I look it up light
was green straw punched it
I had them about two blocks I could have
got away had about two blocks but it was
a Dodge Dart six-cylinder and it wasn't
tuned that but it was backfire so I made
a left turn over my floor back into a
locker when I'm trying to give
evidence I got to be a lord made a right
turn to another bag out the window went
down a block I'm doing like a cheer
through his bag heat the top and when to
him broke open it was like a snowstorm
in the car look back in my eyes I
couldn't see I didn't have any time
accident but I made it to the jump off
point I know my neighborhood I know
where I put a jump out his car we call
it Bobby Lee out the car and take off so
when I got to 41st Drive the ponies
blocked off you or I'm coming from over
I slammed the car in park open the door
and I rolled out in the car 40 50 miles
an hour
however it stopping whatever speed is
stopping at 25 miles an hour I rolled
out the car to appeal I left parachute
landing [ __ ] yes will taught me that
anywhere I jump up and I start when I
look back the car jumped out of the park
and when you reverse and went back at
the police car
this guy actually testified that I ran
back to the club-footed reverse never
happened the car jump years and went
back all right here to smash I hear the
traffic accident I run through the
shortcut but it's not a shortcut anymore
it's built up that got Constantine Y on
the top get close look I'm gonna get cut
up going through there so I said I gotta
get rid of this [ __ ] I take my tote bag
with 1,800 bullets and my automatic 22
rifle I throw it over my head it sells
up and it sells on the roof good all
right reaching a sign I gather 357
Magnum and I throw it this way good
question I thought they would put hot
water back through it I come up with the
song 12-gauge I do like this and it was
slide out right into my hand
well got it out you turn the corner and
I looked at him he looked at me and he
said you black son of a [ __ ] and get
the skinny
I told don't do it man and he stopped
and was at the staring contest he's
standing there he's shaking I said he
smoked I'm finna try he's gonna try it
if we're gonna be hold he tried the
skinny when he tried to skin it I had
him here but I dropped it here and goes
next money
we got a baby seven or eight pellets
birdshot but it was enough because the
five jumped on you seen his whole life
flashed before he dropped his service
revolver he needs a car and I looked at
the girl I said what did you do this
good anyway I took about a barrel that's
nothing I'm not going out there where I
just shot a police officer they heard
the bang here they come
I saw over the key and I cut myself up
on a wire I run to the front and a
helicopter drops in on me but I run
counterclockwise the way it's going but
I get you the front I run into the party
next door that closes the gate I run
upstairs and I'm looking for eggs I'm
looking for way out and I just stay
there's nowhere to go
I come back to the friend I sit down
watching helicopter i watch the pulley
they do it house to house to house
search but they never come in apartment
building
three hours later they're leaving they
didn't find me so their agony until
searching researching do detectives and
they'll come up with me that way but
they didn't find me in that search so
they left I said I'm gonna give it about
15 minutes and I'm out of here
this lady comes out the house I knew her
should come out the house oh how are you
doing I said I'm okay many how are you
I'm okay she said well take care as if I
said you singing she closed the door I
knew this lady man helped her carry
groceries in anyway she goes back house
and called police
I didn't know this the police pulled up
in front it's all vacant I'm finna leave
they put up in front and it's out he's
talking right now and he points out
Department field and I stand up and my
heart in my ass dropped to my feet I
know they're coming in so well into the
back I'm going downstairs
I'm gonna do it the open field track and
field obstacle course I go for the door
that has no doorknob I try to stick my
finger in and turn the latch I can't do
it and there's nothing to turn it with I
hear be doing where to Bam Bam Bam Bam
ma'am ma'am come over the window but you
open the door which I'm gonna dog run to
the front
Bam Bam Bam serve so could you come over
the door and it makes me new comes out
you look at hallway
I said get your mother-fucking turns
ready closed his door ma'am I may be a
man man sorry at your front door the Sun
is behind him as I see the shadow they
got one of their German Shepherds and
his dog is in barking he's whining he's
ready to go get the [ __ ] out of here
I take my shirt off by stuffing in the
mailbox they'd been doing plaster work
on the wall
so we'd run I've ever passing Bag I
thought of myself I go to the door I
open it and I walk out they grab me and
it broke me out of the way they all run
in and I'm walking down the street but
they've got a perimeter I'm making about
halfway to the perimeter and once I got
stopped in Judy's and honest all kind of
stuff taking back to the car they say
we're gonna do an open field line up I
know who totally because it's the only
person who seen so I
inconspicuously and look up at her
window and I see the curtain over yeah
that's him we got him [ __ ] I'm like you
for seven years
I thought of a thousand three ways I was
gonna kill me I was gonna throw a snake
in her house that's right before I gonna
be isolated that's how I do stress
because I came up with some pretty
exciting way because I was gonna get
every but she died and I was like better
her than me
death 33 prisons in California I've been
in 24 from Pelican Bay down to chuck of
water and Pelican Bay is the worst place
I everybody was so miserable I had
migraines I couldn't sleep I had to go
to a psychiatrist the plates was I'm
dreaming the prays had teeth this
washing was trying to kill me man they
even stress me out
it took me three years ago out here I
took him to court I sued
change of location when the court
ordered them to see me South they see me
to the next your 300 yards south like it
was a joke
I told her I contacted the court in
total nine you know they turn this into
a joke
the judge ordered Amex it either seen
this man itself I'm having brought near
you're gonna explain why it's not going
that's an order
see me itself a while every prison I've
been here I had to fight first had a
fight with a black because I don't
particularly talked the same way I mean
honey I was in a silly lemon much and I
never said that to myself before you
Levin much he couldn't believe it I
never said a word to him on the yard for
17 months a Tracy I never said that
anybody wanna do the Jake in he can't
talk he don't say no no I just decided
not to speak to him they wouldn't talk
about anything I wanted to use country
country was the largest doodle New York
six hundred pounds I mean this to live
so much weight you can't get him all of
the bar the bar has been like a you and
he's lifting this dude had three years
he caught 39 more years for 18 Rick's he
raped man he was called a booty bandit
rape you one particular day country
turned his on eyes on me I'm coming off
the yard and you gotta get serfs to come
off the yard and kind of say hey man I'm
gonna [ __ ] you tonight I said what they
said you gonna be my [ __ ] I'm away your
ass out I've been watching you you got a
nice ass
that's it okay turn around come up the
guy's a pat me down don't went to my
seal you know a swing myself was to 14
the doors are nomadic so I'll call the
guard open to 14 you look and see as you
push the button to open I'm waiting put
my gloves on put my long sleeve shirts
on got my best boot tied above no tight
jeans real sensitive and when stood by
the door so I'm standing by the door
with an apathetic expression country
walks behind me he's talking to somebody
he's engaged in conversation okay excuse
me what you want man
I say remember you're supposed to be
[ __ ] me man oh yeah you come over
there everybody heard this everybody got
quiet you guys can't do anything until
it happened so we go to the third seat
and open three
we walk off in a sail a country chansu
shirt off like Hong Kong be like the
rest of us like Teddy shadow he showed
me all these muscles things and yeah
bring you ass in here [ __ ] so I
generally step off for the sale clothes
339 the seller will come across in the
clothing lock country swung at a 100 and
I jumped out of my cart want a picture
and I big the largest piece of chicken I
ever bid money I pay the chunk I just do
so big blood squirted out of him but it
was on in my mouth because I severed it
he started screaming and I spit kill you
smother me again
I jumped on his back and I bit him on
the other side I've been to I mean I
don't know what jaws would open it for
us
I didn't nice gigantic chunk out of him
and I split it on the floor now
he knows he's locked in a cell with a
cannibal he came to [ __ ] I mean it he
says I mean you know so you swung at me
again and I tried to bite his nipple off
but I got up love it and I hate a lot of
picture I've been a large so largest
country wine in the cellar he's ready to
get away from me and I've changed my
mama I've broken my Wang I made this
[ __ ] up we fight for about 30
minutes and I'm tired he tried I got my
hands on my leaning I'm saying I'm
feeling in this he's standing up and I
know he's finish wing a because he's
doing like kid you don't know what you
money on bites - hold on - he's bleeding
like a slider peeing and then bites
country is still screaming and crying
I'm gonna kill this [ __ ] stop
punching me the boss
I get them - real good clear features
please my hand passes and I grab me
think I put it on I tried to bite that
[ __ ] off my cell my bite this
[ __ ] deal I must e'en never
raped nobody else and I'm trying to get
the end remember country stones not
gonna work
in fact I'm trying to get I just want
least nippy a razor cut anything
I hate too hard I'll come back if it's
under TV he came out with a cone and
swore I don't know there isn't open the
open the door everybody thought I was in
there getting killed they feel sorry for
you on the screaming they just knew he
was just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me I
stepped out that cell I have a mark only
country had a broken nose three gigantic
hoes he didn't know how he was gone me
like two black eyes because when the
walls broke - I smell for some reason
and everytime country came around me
it'd get quiet when you walked in the
room when I was there it would get quiet
so I know he was dead and I would stand
up and I turn to look at him he looked
at me he makes his mean expression they
turned and he walked out the door for
about three months this is when Frank
had Knox but I miss my book up here I
know what I'm gonna do so he'd come up
to me what he said to me let me talk to
you [ __ ] I'm sorry about that man you
ain't gonna work on me on I was wrong
you're right man you got me you better
man you're gonna work on the more I said
alright country left every time I see
him I still stood up and watched his ass
I'm gonna give him a break but that's
how I got the booty man I hate us in
that cell
okay here in uh
16 2016 they started a program called
MRCP means really Community Program it's
like the halfway house
so there are 17,000 individuals who
qualify by location in Los Angeles there
are 10,000 that qualify because they
meet two criteria there are 3,000 that
were interviewed with the only 400 that
made it because somebody said let's try
this guy this guy is intelligent he got
seven different college degrees you got
17 certified vocational skills which is
what I had he writes screenplays and
management he stays busy types 83 words
of me honest is autodidact got try
myself I speak four languages I taught
myself Spanish by reading the Spanish
Bible from Genesis to Revelation cuando
yo complete the island where they live
and sleeping how long and la I'll get
some in [ __ ]
I speak four languages and I taught
myself nobody taught me it's just like I
said I retain 90 to 95% of anything I
read I read four thousand one hundred
seventy eight books in 31 years I know
because I count her what he took place
in was they made the decision to send me
they interviewed me asked me did I want
to go yeah you don't want to go to the
street so about a week later I was on
the van handcuffed in the van we went in
the alley across from MacArthur Park the
van comes off and you can run but if you
willing we're gonna give you like one
strike you're out if you got strikes
Villa I got fifty two strikes I have 52
altered rounds each round was account so
I got fifty two strikes so anyway uh I
went to MCM CRP program and for about
eight months and I completed the program
my time
my parole came and they keep down the
front door
my mom died like about three months
before I got him over there my mom was
the last thing was my last anchor she
would kill me in place and she tried to
wait she said she'd be there when I came
home she tried she didn't make it
my mama had Parkinson's and Parks it in
this car down this it's a dysfunctional
disease because it in a text and nervous
system and the person is trying to move
but all they're doing is shaking and it
starts with the smaller muscles facial
muscles in the neck I mean I learned so
much of my partner my mom's start going
through it because I would talk to her
father and she would ask me questions
and I had to answer because I remembered
a lot of what I read that's how I got
that's how I got down here and my dad I
stopped caring I stopped caring and just
people I'm coming here to live people
come here to die and a Tuesday who gonna
come here live I wouldn't but I would
definitely come here nice great job
everybody doing
[Applause]
Paul needed a I said I'll just be here
three years
I got 16 October 17 16 where he's little
baddest first Anna I still the street I
stay there I see the tip for I'm gonna
just are standing for us for the past
four months you know that's what it
means
I just I used to sleep on the sidewalk
oops a man I saw you gonna sidewalk
grayed out could have got us s only
chance you got to get me you better give
me one sleep because you can't do
anything what I want I watched I watch
The Avengers and Captain America told
doctor didn't matter he said never be a
good time you get angry doctor dr. Dave
Mattison that's my secret I'm always
angry that's me I'm always angry I came
out angry even if I smile as I stay
angry but I'm directly
I'd to make your [ __ ] people I mean I'm
not God I don't have this sense I think
this is a judgement people to have
[ __ ] people that and I change the way
they look
I've had thirty two fights down here and
there's thirty two people who look
different now they have lacerations
abusing subdural hematomas that won't
ever go away because I changed the way
they look I tell them if you can't fight
for an hour
don't [ __ ] with me I'll even let you win
the first ten or fifteen minutes but I'm
a half 45 minutes beating your
[ __ ] ass systematically and I'm
going to do it I must spend a whole hour
just remember just taking you apart
that's how a man
doc hit me in the chest with his Shepard
I took the shell phone I choked him out
till he passed out I let him go I set on
his chest I slapped him til he woke up I
said now here's the ass-kicking I
promised you and for about 30 minutes
this all face shot is just beautiful my
hands broke but even when I was broke
ours village is mainland that's a I
never go started I don't go looking for
it they have to say something to me
because I don't do a lot of talking I am
associate I'm not anti-social I don't
care who you socialize with I'm a social
your friends are my friends I don't
socialize I my brothers down here my
younger brother and I kind of you kind
of want on whose name live alone if you
don't say that - you don't like you
either like you or you don't there's no
greater but I never did that - I don't
know something about something like the
way you cut your hair
but either I like them or I don't if I
like them I talked to all my smiles
don't come easy because I don't have
nothing to smile about
not really if people say well you're
alive only because I have it you know
deliberately but I have studied 99.7%
effective is Jennifer Metrorail each
wolf each will is against tonight 97%
effective is the shotgun to the mouth
92% effective is jumping from ability of
a building on our platform that would
allow you to exceed 80 miles an hour
$70 86% effective is pinging yourself
but you gotta get away you gotta get rid
of everybody and send him on vacations
and get away from him
that's what Robin Williams did because
he studied it people want to die they
know how they're gonna do it you can't
stop us people who tell you to go down
make a phone call they want to teach you
the ones who are going to do it they
don't talk about it they don't tell
nobody
that's why such a shock I studied it I
stood I forgot it
and I wait sorry
something good might happen something
good might happen but I'm like Evel
Knievel you don't give a [ __ ]
you got an edge I would go [ __ ] I don't
go look for him I don't know what out
there like [ __ ] is darkwing duck are
underdogs infra cane I know fear I don't
know what idea when your daughter come
out to Club is she drunk
I'll make sure she'd get in the car I
don't touch it I make sure she gave me a
car and she can sleep there and nobody
gonna mess with her I'm gonna stay right
there like a watchdog
I want to make sure your son when he
comes down here at time I shouldn't go
down there but if he has to come down
here to purchase drugs I tell her I'm
gonna get you in and I'm gonna get you
out only thing you gonna do is you're
gonna do exactly what I tell you what I
tell you to do and don't say nothing to
nobody
and I can assure you you'll live through
this experience I do that I go up the
air walk women today Corey not to get
out because I only love one and she
don't love me she doing something
different but I make sure they get there
because somebody warm home safe if
they'd been drinking I'm trying to talk
to him today sober up because I don't
drink imagine me drunk it'd be a whole
bunch of black guys around here because
drunk my best but a sober mind wants to
do and I've been pushing everything a
lot of girls marry with black guys doing
prepared every deal anyway that's what I
do at nighttime I'm gonna help people
somebody got to I'm a if I can't I don't
feel I love the underdog and I'm going I
try to help if they don't want it I'm
trying to like hang around and make sure
they get away because I'm going to
either me I'm gonna care to me because
I mean I give a [ __ ] about you I just
became to met with me let me I don't
give a [ __ ] if you kill me you'll be
doing me a favor
so as I got here that's what I'm doing
here am I going to stay here I can leave
any time I wore to any time any day and
I got I did
murders me and our ideals I do a lot of
time to think about it and I've worked
every judgment I can do I just can't
type anymore because my left hand
doesn't work anymore but I don't tell
nobody I don't put it out to you because
that's a disadvantage somebody take
advantage of that I don't know if I can
use that me and no I can't I can't open
but directly is the one that's going to
get you that's what I